the Tesla Model y looks absolutely
stunning with white seats but does that
mean you have a problem on your hands or
do you need to protect them to make sure
they stay pristine and white
well after six months of owning the
Tesla Model wire I can guarantee you you
need to protect them to make sure
they're perfect so today we're going to
show you exactly what you need to do to
protect these white seats and guarantee
they're good for a lifetime before you
start protecting your white seats you're
going to need to clean them down
thoroughly first thing first is you're
going to need some Castile soap the
Castile soap can be purchased from any
pharmacy or even online there is a
product that Tesla recommended to us
directly but unfortunately we can't seem
to get our hands on it so Castile soap
which is basically soaked without any
chemicals inside it will do just fine
you're then going to need it to put it
into some sort of spray bottle now on
the back of the packet of this one it
recommends one part Castile soap three
parts water to create a diluted solution
you then simply going to spray the
solution on the white seats wipe it down
with one microfiber cloth and then come
back and dry it off with a second when
you're ready simply spray a few squirts
from the bottle of the Castile soap all
over the seats and make sure you spray
one of two squirts on the actual cloth
itself now I recommend that microfiber
cloth because they're always just that
little bit better and a little bit
softer what you'll notice is I sprayed a
little bit of way too much Castile soap
on these seeds and the actual cloth
ended up becoming quite soapy so I
continued to spray it without realizing
until the very end you want to actually
squirt a few less squirts than what I've
shown in this video just to make sure
you don't have too much residue all over
the seeds however after a few little
scrubs and a couple wipes over the
actual seeds they ended up looking just
as bright just as white as they were on
day one when you finish with the Castile
soap you want to come back with a second
microfiber cloth and give it a good wipe
down you don't want to leave that
residue sitting all over the seats and
penetrating into the vegan leather
that's going to leave stains and it's
not going to look good in the long run
so make sure you give it a very very
thorough wipe down and make sure there
is no residue whatsoever left on these
seats in preparation for the leather
Shield now that you've cleaned your
seats and potentially even vacuumed your
car to make sure everything is Spot Free
you're ready to use your leather shield
now make sure you read your leather
Shield instructions all the way through
because there are YouTube videos out
there that tell you you only need to
wait 12 hours but in fact actual fact
when you read the instructions it's
going to tell you you need to wait 24
hours you need to make sure the vehicle
is inside no humidity no sun so you want
to do this inside your garage wherever
possible the leather Shield itself is
actually incredibly easy to apply all we
need to do is take out the applicator
spread a few little drops on the cloth
and then go over all of your leather
surfaces if you do see a little bit of
streak marks make sure you reapply it
within 15 minutes and immediately wipe
off generally speaking the leather
Shield is not meant to leave any residue
not meant to leave any marks and when
you sit in your car next time you might
feel a slight change in the leather just
because the coating is there however
after a while that have dissipate and it
won't be like anything was there ever to
begin with now typically the leather
Shield recommends that you test a little
portion of the leather Shield somewhere
on a discrete location obviously this
being a second application we don't need
to actually test it again because we
know it's pretty good so I went ahead
straight away and started wiping over
the passenger side seat you want to
continuously use a single motion lift
pull and drag you want to be able to
apply that texture coat as smoothly and
evenly as possible without too much
residue now obviously this becomes quite
challenging as the seats curve and
Contour but you want to make sure you
try and get into every nook and cranny
when you come across to the front seats
try and make sure you get underneath as
much as you can of that headrest because
it can't actually move but a little bit
of dust and debris definitely goes in
them you also want to make sure you get
into all the corners as much as you
possibly can and don't forget about the
back of the headrests when you move to
the rear side of the vehicle once 24
hours has passed and you see it's
completely dry you only have to clean
them with water wipes now this is
basically just baby wipes with no
chemicals again added to them because
this is vegan leather you want to make
sure you don't put any chemicals on them
to ruin the leather now I will say
before we go too much further that
whatever we've done in this video we've
done it on our own Merit it is our
responsibility and our liability
whatever you do on your own please take
some caution and some care because what
we've done may not work for you it is
just my opinion on how to keep these
seats clean for us anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and if you
have any questions make sure you leave
them in the comments but like always
I'll see you next Monday